uh going up with a man named jay
is pretty good
he did not bring his guitar he brought
his guitar with us maybe we'll see him
it out and serenade you is that
something you'd be into
ariana are you into um musical dudes
does this guitar do something for your
nether regions
[Music]
[Applause]
go ahead and pick up the microphone and
put it right by your mouth about an inch
away
and go on a date starting now
okay so um
i'm assuming you live here in austin and
uh
yeah what kind of stuff you wanted to do
here
well i guess i'd like to go for long
walks on ladybird what do you like to do
here
i'm uh i'm kind of a barton springer
myself so that's where i spent most of
my times actually just our lifeguarding
there so i'm there all the
yeah
time
just like going to music and comedy of
the mics um
yeah yeah but uh when you're on these
walks on the lake um
are you in a meditative state or not at
all not at all
just raging just raging mostly i would
say my favorite thing to do is mostly
just like get really mad people who take
up the whole space for no reason
[Music]
um
[Music]
like while you're walking like you're
walking and you're just like oh you're
right
okay so you're you're a power walker
okay yeah like four nph or like fast
food
anytime
you wanna
you asked what do you like to do which
is a very vague question in austin who
made it a little more specific what uh
what do you like to do
um i like to
yeah i like to write songs music is a
big part of my life i do comedy music so
i like to do that they're doing that for
a few years and i also
just love
uh i guess doing like zen sessions at
barton where i just lay on my back for
like six hours straight and just kind of
stare at the sky and
just you know let my mind just go this
guy's really trying to get laid yeah
just go like completely what a wonderful
answer so jay what uh what's your dating
life like who haven't been dating
recently um
it's been a lot of um
masturbating um
are you masturbating a lot
well mostly chocolates women at barton
springs
[Music]
did you just hear what did everyone else
just hear what orianna said probably no
fella on this stage is listening she
likes to masturbate to the topless women
and martin springs not the dudes that
are laying on their back for six hours
just waiting for somebody to crawl on
top you know you gotta do a little work
sweetheart just right right oh i'm just
going to call you ariana you're uh
you're you're bisexual it's happy month
for you
[Music]
everyone's on the jail congratulations
am i bisexual
um
[Music]
another person being bisexual you beat
myself
[Music]
for a while
you're curious yes yes isn't that
another flavor in the alphabet by
curious
that's one two she's like a vc
yeah
you know i've been sucking that dick bc
[Music]
[Music]
oh
will never know the joys of sucking your
dick to get ahead he's a straight
straight man i'm not opposed to it if it
means
you will be dead giving ahead
i will be giving you ahead of this life
you'll be giving it okay enough head
jokes my god does it never end
orianna back to you love when is the
last time you've been on a date and when
was it with a
lady or was it with a fella
[Music]
okay
and describe this guy was he mute of the
musical like type was it what was he um
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
i don't know
[Music]
but maybe she's like no today's lady day
tonight
okay so what is it that she goes to lady
ladybirds
[Music]
[Music]
what types of musical comedy do you do
like is it is it one line
i really just want to hear it
no acapella i get beat bugs
foreign
the tempo is so
fast all right what what do you think
about the economy are you vaccinated um
yes
yes actually
but he has a haircut of uh
ariana are yeah vaccinated
of course of course
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
to come
[Music]
jay what do you think about donald trump
jr
um
i'm not gonna lie i don't really know
that much about him i'm not a big news
follower he doesn't pay attention to
things yeah from austin
where are you from
i'm from georgia
yeah he's a georgia boy
uh
does that make you feel better that he's
from georgia or worse
uh what uh what do you miss about
georgia
not even the coca-cola museum
school there
when did you decide that you were into
women was it in georgia did you find a
few peaches out there that's in college
okay the experimental phase when did you
get out of college
got okay baby fresh snug out here
pretty much
so how are they
pretty much
where is the first lady that you you
know when you cemented the deal in
college whereabouts
do you also keep in touch
of course this all started you [ __ ]
your roommate in college
was that weird for the rest of the time
it's like why isn't this happening all
the time
oh my god our roommate story like hey do
you have a sibling story with a dude
um
no no not yet but i recently
uh have gotten two new roommates so i
think we could have doors
increases your chances man yeah yeah
jason gay soon
by the end of this show
that's my mission
did we have like extra men in the bucket
or something
yeah would you like to come back again
with the dude
honestly i'm deaf
[Music]
so how did it happen was she drunk were
you drunk was there a party where did
you guys just get stressed out because
of a group project or how do it go
down and
[Music]
it
hispanic
organic
so uh what who went down the move was it
a 69 situation
jerry's about to go to sloka park right
now way down on his back
she's speechless much like she was when
she was a [ __ ] like by a roommate in
college
i feel it right now
but these experiences you've had to date
which since 2022 so it's like three
years of
experimenting hasn't been enough for you
to go full
painting full painting
is that wrong might not always say
what did you spell out with your tongue
were you supposed to she definitely is
an asian you definitely want to get uh
cunnilingus tips from han's kid
sure
i actually have a small jaw or a small
it's hard for me to really get in there
[Music]
[Music]
for longer just like your uh driving
business your mexican family orianna
would you go out with jay again
would you all spend some time together
outside of this amazing comedy club
[Music]
[Applause]
what was your experience in georgia like
and don't say anything bad about this
microphone
uh
i was up in north georgia
um
and so yeah there wasn't a whole lot
going on
like toccoa georgia
so it kind of
no i have a short tongue unfortunately
it's got uh
it's like you've got this thing that
it's a support group for a short time
yeah yeah i know i feel you honest i i
i've got a short little tongue it
doesn't stick out very well i'm looking
for a man that can tongue of [ __ ] right
now yeah she'll have the key to
orianna's heart
[Music]
she doesn't want it keep your tongues in
your mouth man
what prompted you to put your name in
this bucket
uh are you are you is it tough out there
on the streets i mean what's going on
out in austin a texas
two minutes are like not having a lot of
luck are you on the apps
[Music]
batman
[Music]
is he paying you with drinks or
something i see you got some snacks over
there okay
uh i feel like i was already
kind of
being turned down which i totally get we
only had one minute
people so intensely you know i'm in a
war do i
yeah are you a veteran
even now
i mean i was in prison but only for like
only like
uh no i i actually wasn't it wasn't
imprisoned um
it's a really escalating dance there
yeah you're freaking out
okay so we're not gonna find out
anything about
your ptsd
tonight
no no it's from other things yeah he's
wearing a shirt with every braided puppy
on it
it's like
101 dalmatians but it's beethoven um
[Music]
your shirt is wrinkled as [ __ ]
oh yeah i don't actually like full
launcher we got morgan weinball on
canvas from last week and colin quinn
[Applause]
i mean quinn calling
conquest
but uh yeah i mean uh we got more
comedians coming up jay do you do you
dabble in comedy so you do open mics
i came to austin for
yeah for comedy and music and i i do all
comedy music you're like austin as a
person you do music and comedy right now
do you also lift kettlebells and eat elk
funny enough that was my prior life yeah
before music yeah it was a lot of meat
and
now you're doing music and you're a
vegan
yeah yeah i was
trained in dogs for cats
yeah yeah
[Music]
just move it is that why your shirt is
so wrinkled because all your stuff is in
the back of a car right now um
yeah i moved it about three months ago
so it's not like a three month period in
your car
uh i'm actually living in a room uh
[Music]
of them we is them
for you guys
it is i want you is that van for sale
you can keep it for restaurants is that
where you put your kids
i mean you have children when my kids
come of age yeah they need to know
the way like what is it you know we
walked five miles in the snow without
shoes no i your daddy lived in a van
look at him now you need to know that i
lived in a van on uphill and downhill as
well
[Music]
love to iron jay's shirt go on a road
trip with him
[Music]
i do like road trips
road trip
from georgia all the way to austin when
did you move here i lived here
[Music]
oh okay
right after her first sexual escapade
she was like it was so good i had to
flee
do you still talk to that girl
[Music]
i love him
she's a really lovely person did you
look her [ __ ] again
she's like she's like mine
so it's totally platonic now nothing no
nothing that sparks flying anymore
jill reminisce about that once no but
she's a baddie so she's very lucky
is she here
you can't love the people you're a
stephen sexual
what uh what won't you find
those things
congratulations
you really were raised in georgia
uh jay what's what's your deal like what
what do you think about this like she
licked [ __ ] like is that okay
what's the difference
i did grow up
like a very you know my parents were
actually missionaries so i was like a
missionary kid
so you hate that position so like
yeah
oh yeah hardcore yeah hardcore but then
i i think like i'm doing comedy now is
like going the opposite direction of
that [ __ ] yeah
stick it down yeah we're getting [ __ ]
those hardcore missionaries we're
getting the baptist back
the guys oh
yeah yeah but we put potato sacks on
double twin beds my mom had this story
when she went to seminary people there
would like cheat the system by they
would make up for a pillow that was like
how they would how they would yeah
really [ __ ] the system there yeah
making out with the pillow really
sticking it to jesus
docking
so it's basically like we can't have sex
but
if someone else is in the room you put
your penis in someone you just sit there
and that means you're just talking
that's not so cute
[Music]
holy [ __ ]
i think jay just came
he really enjoyed that that was
you're quite amazing storyteller you do
a lot of wonderful things with your
tongue
[Music]
thank you so much
so what what would you say to jay if you
were to like you know give him advice on
dating like maybe
his eyes supposed to be dry as [ __ ]
right now
it definitely doesn't have contacts
[Music]
[Music]
hey don't start talking bad about
yourself just to adjust yourself to him
okay do you understand me classic woman
yeah
[Music]
yeah they'll take an inch and grab the
whatever
you uh show an inch of weakness around
this guy he'll [ __ ] storm the capital
or
on overhead
jay what do you think about uh going on
another date with a man are you down for
that well he's gonna come back and
serenade someone i think he's gonna
throw his name back
okay
well you can always call on jay jay is
like
fun a friend he'll come up here with
guitar
what's your go to wonder wall
just depends on the mood i mean most of
them are like dick songs
um
yeah yeah
we don't need to read between the lines
with this anymore okay everyone like
he's putting it out there he's gay
is it yours hey delilah
yeah is that all you know
that's a good song
is it the only song
good song for little soy boys
[Music]
[Applause]
watch your step
all right
we got quinn coming up a female
comedian
and i have prairie
very
[Music]
are you in
austin i just got here seven days ago
seven days ago from where
seattle seattle i've never been to
seattle this guy's from seattle i think
only half listen to people that's
probably not a good thing to say on a
date i'm so sorry it's all good
i should let you know i really hate
seattle
hey did you move to austin
i lived here
okay yeah
so right now i'm living in the hospital
um
are very cool
uh ernest hemingway wrote so much of
feral to arms in a hostel did you know
that that's pretty cool
i don't know
look at us just do you like literature
you like reading
yes i read quite often i [ __ ] hate
reading
[Music]
i like to know cool literature facts
though so i seem really cool mysterious
that's my personal favorite
uh winter tattoo is very it's actually a
reference to a feral honor spider-man
i made that up uh i just thought it was
cool
and time she thought it was cool quit
colin going today with jay
give
that's jay from last time barry uh
you're from seattle why do you hate
seattle so much is it because there's so
many people that quit there
no
i'm from pennsylvania i was just in
seattle for a week
okay so you really don't know [ __ ] about
seattle that's where i'm from [ __ ]
i know enough
philadelphia were you born and raised on
the playground who's worries
i was born in the mountains
in a small town
i lived next to them
on you're dead okay
very quick
well he lives around that i'm sure he's
bumped into that a couple times
i can't believe it's not better
[Music]
no but i should be there literally right
now i'm from houston where are my
houstonians at anyone
no one
oh my god
from california
i also lived there for a long time i
don't know where i'm from this is where
i'm here now
it's mary where are you right now
you said you were from seattle you are
not no i lived there
i probably people misunderstood the
questions like black real awkward if i
were to see your birth certificate and
it doesn't say seattle
are you the first black president barack
obama
cannot confirm
politician for sure b.o jr right here
thanks for the health care recallion
in texas going with the risky hostile
vulnerability
you were like hey i'm going to reveal
something so that i live in a hostel
right now you're even worse than jay
over there with his wrinkled shirt
his shirt's at least pressed decently
[Music]
most of the time i'm upright so i think
that makes up for it you know i don't
lay down very much
i honestly didn't even know there were
hostiles in austin that's an interesting
way to say you don't get laid thank you
[Music]
do you live at the firehouse hostel yes
yes downtown
accommodations
wow that's actually that's pretty
impressive yeah him and uh
all the homeless people everyone else on
6th street um
wow
community they lived in a hostel was it
firehouse christina
i think they all have legitimate homes
yeah i didn't want to say her last name
but she did it hey she lived in a hostel
what a loser huh no one
has shitty accommodations or lives in a
van
it's like hotel seasons where all the
jokes and murders are allotted you know
colin
what is your uh tattoo actually about
it's not a farewell to armor yeah it's
nothing i had money it was cool that is
all
what did let me see it
i had money and where did you get that
done in seattle no i got under done uh
uh true blue i actually visited austin
in september with one of my friends
because i had just gotten dumped and i
was like i'm gonna get a tattoo and i
was like planned on getting asleep but
then i was like really like boston so i
just moved here instead of getting to
sleep
that's nice we'll take your
huddled masses you're broken up your
side your
everyone who's broken up with it
depressed
that's awesome
and then you came here and now you live
here i do i do live here this is your
spirit animal in this city
yeah that's cool
my spirit animal is this city
you got a tattoo here now you live here
yeah now you're on a date with barry
here it's like all meant to be
barry why did you come to austin first
seven days ago that's so wild
it's like every comic i mean yeah i just
got here seven days ago yeah
so i got a job here um
i was trying to escape seattle so
that's is it that bad
for me yeah what do you hate about
seattle i'm from the east coast it's
very west coast it's not the world but
for me
yeah all that free weed and healthcare
what do you do like what's your job
i'm the instructional designer for a
large tech company wow wow that pays
like six figures dude
i know
[Music]
seriously he's gonna be out of that
hostel in no time
he's really waiting you gotta ever hurt
this guy oh my god drove on the table
right yesterday for 15 minutes
that's the new amber alert everywhere
nice not the one on your phone
[Music]
i
actually i'm just not really not looking
for a man that's the thing oh you're
like
[Music]
a lesbian no i'm just like i'm not
looking for a relationship currently
okay you want to be which is something
that people say i feel like and
immediately find a relationship so
that's why i'm saying that that's
perfect you're trying to reverse
psychology yeah people like as soon as i
quit caring about finding love in my
life they just like felt like this
film's my lap so i keep saying like i
don't care at all about meeting the love
of my life just a lot are you a comic
too i am yeah so the odds will never be
in your face no and i like if when
you're only around comments you don't
date comics it's just
like a lot of volunteers happened yeah
i've got an instructional design
engineer yeah i'm going to set that job
title right
i'm just going to keep adding and now
what this is
[Music]
just give yourself your own job title
yeah just make something up that's not
always equate to more money
right what did you do in your early
years in philadelphia with the amish
i'm from strasbourg
you don't like food
when you say me are you speaking in this
is from you and the amish he's from
delaware
do you also love dogs and outdoor bars
that's awesome i have mixed feelings
about dollars the outdoors is okay
[Music]
i'm kind of a weird person so no way
[Music]
okay so i spent a lot of time with
computers so my social skills are
they're suffering yeah i'm really
connecting with you as an asian man
i mean
i really like rush hour we could do that
if you want you know
have you learned to talk autism yeah
uh i well i am
i've only been on very like
few days since i've moved here and
they're all a very uh like polar
opposite like dudes that i like
definitely
like
do not have a real job or like dudes
that have it all together
and i can tell you which one gets the
second
[Music]
not like so he was poor
i mean i guess he's smart though he
wasn't dead is what it is
ladies that means he's dead
he's actually jewish
i know i would be the kind world war
yes the great purveyor of jewish
heritage the nazis
i feel like every show there's somebody
that comes up and haunts us you know
they're a jew you're just like yelling
at me
well barry is black
these are thank you
[Music]
[Music]
was it better to stay in a hostel or
your van or your van
my van i could master right there
are you dating a lot of hipster chicks
in seattle
[Music]
i try to avoid them
so it was kind of complicated i moved to
seattle
i didn't realize my friend convinced me
to move there
i didn't realize she was in love with me
but she was like dating a girl
and then
i got weary outside left it's the short
version oh there's too many women this
is actually just a plot to sleepless
[Music]
so you were weirded out by like the
amount of [ __ ] being thrown out here
like i gotta get back to my computer
let me open the window let's start small
let's just do some anal grow and grow
i'm gonna go to austin get a little more
practice and then you can go back that's
like a normal seattle relationship is a
lesbian and a dude
isn't it just his relationships
many people could you fit in your van
uh at least
two women in one day oh nice specific
jay
nothing so much
what was so weird about this lesbian she
wanted to suck your dick all the time
she was just very forward and i didn't
know how to handle it
like can you text message me this
sexual advance
no it was uh
it wasn't that it was weird it was just
like very unexpected so i don't know i
felt i felt weird about it it wasn't
it's just
i don't know if i'm explaining it this
is still trying to contact you
no no did you you block all that
for now yes for now it's hard to do that
huh
like you always forget some place in the
modern world there's so many methods of
communication but [ __ ] and
[Music]
[Music]
like the basics and they don't email you
after like
they just didn't hear but emails when
you block an email address they still go
somewhere they go to spam
and then i think that's how you know
that they're not the one that if you
block them on anything and they didn't
try to email you after they just weren't
the one yeah they didn't even try to
hack you you're an industrial engineer
how would you hack into that
instructional concept instructional
instructional engineer
you're making like picture books well
usually i
usually do that so
we are better at your job than you are
um but uh yeah if you were trying to
hack on the quinn's uh well how would
you contact her what what what app would
you use that you don't think she would
expect
i don't use apps i only talk to girls in
person
and how's that working out for you
pretty great actually so they've been
here seven days and look what's
happening you're already on a date he's
doing pretty good
how great has it been so far
um i got really acquainted with uh some
of the views
everyone said what
europeans
you aren't the dominant race in america
no the ones at the hospital the real
ones what kind of european
that's a whole continent
right yeah
you can't you can't tell us with
specific breed
but it makes it more fun are they
russian
are they crazy
is it rude if i say i can't tell the
difference
no no
no
reverse racism
yeah
so we're going back to the rush hour i
think is that searching back to them
luckily i can understand every word
coming out of this guy's mouth and
speaks very easily
[Music]
did you go to college
yeah
i did undergrad and grad school
so when you get your instructional
design was that like a certificate like
or was that what you did your bachelor's
in
i went to undergrad for business
management and then i did a grad program
in instructional technology where'd you
go to school university pennsylvania
it's a small school so i'm just law
school too
yeah where i went to etsu eastern state
university
she forgot that's how good our education
is
educational we're the number one easiest
school to get to in the state of
tennessee not to brag hey there's
nothing wrong with uh higher education
uh maybe you'll get a job one day
like
barry
has fallen on what does he do
what do i do yeah um i have a degree in
like communications and like
business management i do sales off and
on i wasn't sales but i didn't like the
job
so are you selling
[Music]
broad sales stuff
i feel like saying you're in sales is
just like
if you say you're oh yeah i do sales
unless you come to specifics it's kind
of like saying that you're like
accounting everybody's like as soon as
you're looking only advanced now like in
austin like i went on a date and i told
them
yeah
is that another thing
barry what do you think about uh quinn's
uh career choices
i mean different tools
only one woman at this time
[Music]
sure
sure sure that's the best i'll take it
you can see the shirt it's better than a
baby
yes
most people have a sugar daddy you got a
chocolate daddy
so you're not working now
i know i am okay
but still it's still just sales stuff
and do you work at home from home um i'm
like
switching i like i like remote stuff
better but it's weirdly hard to find in
austin like everyone was like oh and
awesome everybody works remote they just
work from home
but that's like literally not true they
say that you'll work from home and then
you'll be in the office from like 7am to
8pm
so this is really a boring thing to say
yeah you got to come in and show us your
guests yeah elon musk is just writing
about that you're like you better come
to work
yeah the more we can take from workers
the better that's that's how you show
your importance because i feel like
austin is a weird place to like uh want
to move for comedy and then like have a
good degree based job because like it's
so time consuming to do a job like that
like a big real job and like you won't
have time to do that so
hans is the yellow rose hiring right now
i live in walking distance of the red
rose but i have no rhythm i have no
rhythm i took a pole fitness classes
[Music]
it's like you don't have any rhythm so
between the fact you have so much upper
arm strength to be a stripper and you
have to have rhythm it'd just be a bunch
of people like slow clapping for me and
being like she's such a nice person
she's that's how you twerk this you're
very nice
it's just me
what's the difference between the yellow
rose and the red rose i assume you've
been to both of them native american
asians
[Music]
which one
the native americans go to the yellow
rose because
is this true
no they have a monster
[Music]
you can fill up
the last time
i don't do strip clubs what a gentleman
you don't [ __ ] women
have you never been to a strip club
before in your life
no i refuse you're confused
are you vaccinated
against my williams against your eyes
that's how you
there's nothing wrong with strict folks
but they're just all going to hell
there's
yeah it's just you know i mean it's not
like a good line of code is
are you it from experience
dude i love coding duty or something
[ __ ] up when i was growing up there
was this boy that uh went to school with
and his mom was a stripper and she only
had one leg
oh
that's called nugget porn is
i'm definitely
[Music]
not me though what kind of porn do you
watch i don't watch porn
he really is an amish man
he makes hair brushes
you don't watch any porn not even on
accident not ever you just go to dating
shows to not [ __ ]
i people for the experience
look at it he's thrilled right now out
of his mind this is this is part you
don't do strip clubs and you don't watch
porn
[Music]
i think we should do all of these things
in one day
[Music]
until it's time to go somewhere
like doesn't do you watch tv
no he's not having it
it's against his will
there's no tv's in the hostel no tv in
the hospital do you listen to music
i can't like music what kind is it tech
now
all right
my little j
i mean i mostly listen to like 90s red
or
whatever
that's what it's like
this is your little sample
[Music]
that would be funny if i wasn't the king
of a kiss
what is
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
this relationship's over it's never
gonna happen oh okay that's the deciding
vector
wow look at barry
you could really
be strong you gave me women
both of you guys are gonna go get to go
up we got chris s coming up chris
here he comes
[Music]
oh
[Music]
got today princess and l
nice to meet you christy
where are you from
california originally
and you georgia okay when did you move
to austin
i'm actually just busy
[Music]
i just moved here a month ago so i
haven't
been able to explore a lot yet
fresno
it's like central valley central
california
[Music]
yeah george is pretty nice been there
like twice
[Music]
super hot it is but awesome
yes extremely hot i cannot get used to
this weather
[Music]
yeah
you gotta use sunscreen
anytime give it up for l and chris s
[Applause]
this is like a pork
berry doesn't watch
wow that really melted my butter mom's i
don't know i felt some steam going on
this is this is going to be short-lived
you two have to get busy she's maybe
tomorrow
i guess we'll make a lot of beautiful
white children together
yes let's continue the new minority
pure blood
so what's the wildest thing you've done
in fresno dude that's the wettest place
ever a skateboard
bro
have you ever broken anything
i did sprain my ankle once
if my friend had to ride me back on my
skateboard to my house it was only about
a block away but
i was like really good then if you
haven't broken anything it was only at
three stairs pretty small it's called a
california ambulance
yeah it's doing a triple axel downstairs
wow is that your preferred method of
transportation as a skateboard
and not anymore i like bicycling but
so you don't have a car i do have a car
okay
that's the only horse
what do you live in it
no i do not you have a home i do have a
home with a roof
yes for the
like the square footage of the house
three and a half baths uh 43
what are what metrics is how old you are
i think nine and a half
[Music]
brought you to austin this weekend
or not oh my god okay
[Music]
[Music]
that was one of the best bombs
in history
[Music]
christmas how old are you i'm 34. holy
[ __ ]
this is uh this is definitely important
well that was the oldest guy that you've
dated
did you just turn 34
uh are you a cusp about a month and a
half ago okay so freshly let's he's
practically still 33 big technically
totally what part of georgia are you
from i'm from ireland from atlanta
that's not just what he's doing okay got
it
and what brought you to austin
uh please don't say convey nick my
friend
no there's a nick
oh
ruben got a little pinkie
over here
hi nick
hi yeah
[Music]
yeah oh
where's your backpack dude this is your
friend
i always wonder if this guy has a bomb
on him
this is the atlanta bomber
[Music]
torso just talking about what he does on
stage
do you have to go to all the next comedy
shows
i don't have to i want to that's wow
you want to see the same jokes over and
over again yes
what do you like to do in georgia
so i'm a chef so i like to cook
so you can cook
any specific kind of cuisine you
specialize in or do you like it all
i like it all
right
what kind of culinary uh style is it
um so right now it's just like obviously
american but i'm pretty much i'm just
gonna american well you'll be pleased
with me chris
one of the good ones
you have a job right it's a job and a
house i do have a job yes she has shoes
both of them
he blinks
have you ever had an experience with
someone like nick
oh what kind of experience you know a
walk on the brown side
yeah
okay what's what's what was happening in
fresno was there a romance there that
just
oh what happened to the ground i haven't
lived there in a really long time i uh
moved when i went to university
okay so most recently you've been here a
month and a half that's what he's done
yeah
before that i lived in the netherlands
wow
yeah that's as white as you can yeah
exactly aryan brothers
history have you been to a lot of uh
you know
watch i just uh broke up with my fiancee
that's his closest is the worst person
on the planet and here's what brought me
to austin originally so that's why you
should just stay i thought about it
everyone's doing it
but
we i think we can fit we have room for
one more here that's it then i'm closer
yeah no you deserve better than the
hostiles
what does your fiancee do in austin is
he joking
he was an army
well i hope he's been deported i mean
is
he was supported
[Music]
like a green card situation where you're
gonna have to if you married him you
were the only one no okay i just said
sure no it's not that was already
like how much do you really love him
like i hold your whole [ __ ] life in
here yeah
chris are you canadian
no i'm not canadian i'm american oh
thank god you're one of the good ones
being a clubbing american
no health care for you nope oh uh
so you dated this guy who's not even
white and you're going to marry him a
veteran of the armed forces
this wonderful soldier and then what
happened
he was just a complete piece of [ __ ]
ariana i'll tell you
orianna will fix you right now
when you are breaking up with your
fiancee
move in with me
where is he now
uh he's still here he's in austin in the
united states
she's in austin actually in colleen
exactly
it won't be found a dirty six because
he's clean
that was good
all he ever does
is work out
[Music]
that now men that work out just like
pissed me off yeah i'm just like we just
go to the pool can we go get a drink you
have to be in the gym for three hours
really so he wasn't paying attention to
you
he prioritized the army in the
gym wow yeah those guys are super
unattractive
i'm sorry
i'm glad that you hated them because
honestly
travels around by motorcade he's got a
full fleet around him a lot of the times
yeah he's like
i'm pretty
awesome yes you are
yeah yeah
smoke up your ass
so you have a job you're a human being
uh l that uh you know you're not married
or you're not engaged it didn't even
happen
you're a chef
you're picking up food not feeding it to
any of our veterans
s what do you do
i work in online marketing
spamming so for only fans
sorry
so your online marketing is
for who what's the specific product is
it only fans
no not only fans i advertise like beauty
products and home improvements so only
fans yes
some of it's beautiful
wow he's a man with the he knows about
beauty products yeah the right kind of
you know knee shot do you have a
skincare regimen
i do i just started one oh yeah yeah is
it because of your line of work that
prompted this or no but i think it will
help because i learned about it from
that yeah
i'm sure i'll try to sell those
eventually so
what's the line that you use like
tell me do you use like a toner cleanser
with
a serum that also has he has lubriderm
i don't know
i forgot uh
salicylic acid wow
just uh
no that's it dudes like don't
wash your face ladies am i wrong on this
they don't
why can't how come
it's not fair and then they like don't
get sick no
[Music]
let's pretend that uh chris s is a
little uh you know he cuts the
vegetables in your in your uh restaurant
you're a head chef you know you don't
have time for his sniveling little ways
and uh he actually cuts a carrot uh the
wrong way and you're supposed to cut it
lengthwise
you know the other way
uh
let's just let's just say you're yelling
at him and with all your chef like vigor
and you're trying to keep your
restaurant intact can you show us like
what it's going to be like in a
relationship with you two when uh
he maybe like
you know doesn't pick up the tim the
right thing
so i'm a thrower
i just throw things
so there's probably not gonna be a lot
of speaking
it's just gonna
[Music]
maybe you should have been in the army
so i've been told
so i've been told wow
so do you live with your ex-fiance still
no i am when did you break up exactly
december 3rd oh okay of 2021
last year
six months ago i broke up with them and
then fled two days later drove back to
georgia
immediately
and now you're here and now i'm here
so what brought you back is she uh your
friend orianna what did she want to do
here we actually swung on a boat today
[Music]
hopefully do you want to vote
i do not know do you plan to
i don't think so no
maybe to rent one
yeah
for tomorrow you can pretend to own it
i've seen that happen
when you find that out it's not really
worse
definitely got arrested quote face
[Music]
all right well give it up for uh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
we got morgan coming up
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
candace what's uh
what's uh
what's your biz about what are you about
my what
what do you what's what's your biggest
fear
um
snakes
sick
let's see
well i think you look really nice
tonight thanks i like your shirt that i
picked out
yeah candace picked this shirt off me
earlier
do we like to shirt everybody yeah
[Applause]
[Laughter]
supporters
and local
heroes nether hour
band and the karaoke love them
where were you when you got this shirt
this is about an hour ago at the nether
hour show at latchkey hey i wanted
another shirt
uh the sweat started to seep a little
bit through the yellow shirt but now we
are drunk
that's good to know um
[Music]
uh
i'm i'm i'm all about just trying to be
me and just trying to
to get deep inside who i am and just
says dildo in his ass
but i want to just you know be honest
about myself and
if she's into it she's into it you know
okay so that's that's what you would say
on a date i'm all about me uh well this
is a little different because yeah i
mean i know candice a little bit yeah
and we've been we've been pretty heavy
flirty for actually a few weeks now
there's actually been a lot of tension
there's been a lot of tension so this is
uh
it might come through
maybe he's like
i'm manifesting positive thinking yeah a
few weeks
it's been maybe a few weeks she's a
vegan right now
that's the first thing to know
flirting with other people
you know what that's all
that's totally on me
i should have knows not to wipe up beef
juice
impossible beef yeah yeah
but uh this is technically our first
date and i would say it's going pretty
averagely ready
yeah
candace is so nice
candace uh what are you looking for in a
band
everything has to offer you know
oh what the [ __ ] is there anything
earlier who likes beef yes
who wants to be jerky
[Music]
because i flew with her
and then
like a heartbeat in the 20 mile radius
he's single he just i needed a
girlfriend i did have a girlfriend
and now she is out of that i did have a
girlfriend and we broke up and she
became an mma
um
fighter
about being in a relationship with you
maybe
yeah yeah really she wanted to fight
other women you know
and she's just trying to get closer
yeah i am too we're competing
i thought you would going through the
ufc route but you're going through the
backyard route yeah
yeah we broke up and she got mid jiu
jitsu she got her blue belt within a
year
and she can probably take my ass which
just sucks she's really smart
she doesn't want to [ __ ] you or see you
ever again good thing
yeah she sounds good but she doesn't
suck
at you
you are at our house
yes even her house
yeah we moved here together i heard
somebody that happened to somebody else
but yeah we moved here uh together
during pandemicy times
and then once we were released back into
the wild she was like i want to fight
other women that's what she said
hey well
i was perfect how did you two meet prior
to this
little engagement
what was the
comic of jason yeah she's coming she's
friends with gwen formerly of the show
just now
big quinn big big remain
adjacent so you're a chuckle [ __ ]
more like a chuckle
wait you said you were a chug
she said you're a chocolate [ __ ] you're
like no no i'm in production
[Music]
that was your job that's like a it's a
roundabout we found that last week she
works for ninja warrior which is
[Music]
[Music]
she's only in town for away at night
everyone did you hear that one
yeah what's up smoke show
because i'm right now
i'm only flirting with candy
[Music]
what's your dating strategy
in general yes what are you trying to
get
what am i trying to get uh sex is that
the worst thing you don't want a
relationship no i do not i do not want a
relationship you know what i want more
this i want like somebody then i can
have it like i don't want a long-term
relationship or anything like uh
exclusive but like to get to know
somebody and have nice times with them
and also have sex and he wants a
girlfriend without a girlfriend thank
you thank you that is i want a
girlfriend
and have a view of the baby at the same
time
is that the craziest thing to say that i
want is that crazy he just wants the
opportunity to say we're not able to eat
it maybe we could uh
get another shirt if that's what we're
going for um
[Music]
what kind of corn are you into morgan
there was no age limit i was gonna bring
uh uh a mother of four to this actually
uh she got she took found a babysitter
okay you must have a huge dick
that's what
thank you very much
that's the kind of hosting i need yeah
she has four kids
and uh she could find a babysitter
though that's kind of a bummer but
um no absolutely that's great i assume
she has more money than me so i'll let
her figure that out is that what you do
when you're i've never dated a mother do
you offer to pay for the babysitter why
don't you just offer to be the
babysitter and wait around
i offered to play board games with her
and the family
okay
that's what i'm looking for
yeah
hot and friendly and
sexy and has great style and stuff so
i'd say candace candice is a great girl
though we get along even if we don't end
up what kind of girls do you think would
be interested in you mommy
i've offered to hang out with candace a
number of times and she doesn't respond
so so now it's forced now it's not
really just trying to do it
even if we don't end up you know
whatever i think you're a very cool
person i do i do get along
humanity yeah benefits
no benefits quite yet but if they don't
happen she's like she's a great girl
you're you're really benefit is getting
to know her exactly as a person yeah so
what uh what woman do you think like
you know would uh be attracted to like a
kind of woman who would be into yeah
wasn't it
uh i don't i don't i don't i don't know
i mean i can i have a few dates lined up
in the next week i don't know if that
means those are the people that are
into me
it's being generated from uh comedy
usually
to that i think i think there's many
kinds of people who might find me
attractive i don't i don't want to
talk out of school but morgan is jewish
why don't you be talking out of school
what kind of guys who usually come up to
you at buzz mill cafe
i always smell kind of weird though
[Music]
it makes sense i'm saying that this
morning
everywhere i hit on you everywhere we
are
[Music]
i tried instagram calling her at like 1
am and she didn't pick it up
you don't have
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
anderson film for the 17th time
why don't you throw that jerky in the
trash it's 7 30 go take her out to a
[ __ ] dinner
[Music]
what kind of restaurant would i take you
out to it's a berkey
we gotta deport that tofurky you gotta
[Music]
i'll
[Music]
do we feel the tensions
[Music]
on ladybird lake for sure i don't know
what's gonna happen with me in candace i
don't know it's up in the air
i know what's gonna happen
[Music]
[Music]
just a group of women learning how to
fight to spite me
that's sick
that's sick they have like a punching
bag with my face on it that'd be awesome
are you still working in production
right now
for what is their show happening here uh
not right now i'm working on uh getting
some shows together but i just got off
the american warrior
wow so it's like
just coasting right now essentially was
that the one in dallas
[Music]
before
i love austin it's been about a year and
a half it's been super fun i run my show
that this guy got to headline a few
months ago broken zoo
super fun
and uh have a little can i say a little
announcement yeah my uh uh my show
broken zoos at aviator nation once a
month and we just found out that we're
adding a second show to the vulcan
[Music]
i need the money so i can take her out
on a on a very expensive date so our
chemistry can get it it sounds like
candice would be the one paying for the
age absolutely
[Music]
the first woman morgan will touch
since
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
for the very last time yeah for the last
last time
[Applause]
that was the show give it up for lauren
jameson
[Music]
go check her out on any shows thank you
monkey
that would be nice if that was my
instagram but y'all let me know how
thank you guys so much
[Applause]
[Music]
starting at eight o'clock if you guys
want to hang out watching